chris got to do her makeup last look
last looks you know the best part about
this cree is that we're definitely
diagonal that's that's equally bad it is
just in a different way good morning
it's tuesday i am joined today by cree
who plays daisy how are you doing today
i'm doing great i'm not working today
but i'm visiting set just out of pure
pure love for the cast and crew 100 who
is your favorite beatle and what is your
favorite color i'm gonna say what my
sister's favorite is which i'm pretty
sure is ringo and my favorite color is
burgundy
ringo burgundy miner john and green
let's move on thanks for coming to my
party
let's move on let's keep going did you
read the book i did read the book and
it's a gorgeous book i devoured it very
quickly and what interested you about
the role of daisy like was there
something you connected to with her as i
get older i'm appreciating being the
hype man to the people in my life and
it's kind of that thing of i'm not
on the same planet as you i'm i'm not in
the same spot as you but i love you and
i'm here anyway that's something that
that is really powerful in the movie
that i don't know i admit that i don't
know what this is like for you but i
believe you i
left that about daisy and then also she
gets to
make some jokes cree's adwibs at the end
of scenes are
unbelievably funny like some of them
can't be in the movies
every single take you're it's funny in a
different way so i laugh every time like
can you ever hear me laughing i did
yesterday have you seen any of the other
adaptations of john green's books
yes of course i went with my friends and
we brought blankets because we knew we
were gonna like cried it was gonna be
emotional uh for fault in our stars
everyone's seen all your subsequent ones
looking for alaska every paper town
everyone has we've all seen them we've
all seen let it snow because let it snow
starring isabella merced exactly bella
and cree have invented the john green
multiverse
where all of my uh movie adaptations
exist inside of one complicated universe
full of parallel universes yeah i'm just
trying to get cast in the next one
honestly if there is a next one i think
you're a human you may be 35 years old
great i'll age into her puppies or
kittens i like puppies but if i were one
of them i would for sure be a kitten i'm
a house cat yes i like being inside yeah
i like laying in like patches of sun
when i was your age i thought of myself
as primarily an indoor phenomenon yeah
but as i've gotten older i've gotten
kind of interested in outside you are
very outdoors i see it on your social
media a lot and i feel a little bit like
betrayed
have you ever considered writing star
wars fan fiction you're the author so
you can tell me if i'm wrong yeah but i
loved writing growing up and i feel like
everything that i ever wrote as a kid
was like a really
messy
like unintentional fan fiction of
whatever books or shows oh
totally how does it feel knowing how
impactful this story has been for lots
of people and knowing that you're
bringing it to life in a new form i
think everyone has a relationship with
mental health struggles even if they're
not your own i most certainly do so even
reading the book
taking aside auditioning or knowing if i
was going to get the part
meant a lot and i think i saw a lot of
myself and
sort of my mental health journey in asis
i don't think it's lost on any of us
that it's a really important assignment
we have and
we take that really seriously
well thanks grief we have an amazing
costume crew it is correct that's why
i'm hanging out
and indeed why i'm here even though i
have no job other than to eat cheetos
well thank you for letting me be in the
movie john as the person who is in
complete control of every aspect of this
production you're welcome hank i'll see
you on friday i like read you the outro